bans are really interesting to me and
everything you're saying resonates with
me because i come from politics and we
all know that conservatives
on a lot of these lo you know in a lot
of these locations social media youtube
wherever it may be often times will say
i've been banned and they've been
talking about the vaccine or whatever it
is that they're talking about so this
when somebody gets banned to me that
immediately becomes interesting and
that's when i start digging it kind of
reminds me in politics when sarah palin
was chosen as the vice presidential
nominee and all of media landed in
wacilla alaska to try to dig up dirt on
her she suddenly became interesting i
was like okay well they hate her so
there must be something worthwhile here
let me go figure out what it is so i
think that a lot of my political
background kind of bled into this kind
of beautifully and what i did is i went
and not because i'm a huge andrew tate
fan or anything like that but because
he's an interesting figure he's being
talked about he's now been banned i
don't support bans on people i believe
that that's a coward's way out most
people who ban don't have the
intellectual caliber to debate and so
they want to silence people we saw that
happen during the covet times these last
two years i was one of the people that
everyone wanted shut up for just telling
the truth so i get it
and i dug in and truthfully i watched
hours of take content hours and hours of
content i watched the the two things
that i mentioned and i watched long-form
interviews because i wanted to assess
for myself whether i felt that those
little clips were really taking him out
of context and as it turns out
i agree they are that's not surprising
to me
but i had a really hard time being
outraged by him
and
he and i don't see eye to eye on
everything there were definitely times
where i said i don't agree with that or
saw things differently but it wasn't a
situation ever that i saw content from
him that i said this guy needs to be
removed that there was something so
heinous about him or what he was saying
that he needed to be removed so that was
my takeaway and i immediately you know
thought about what's going on when it
comes to big tech thought about the
people that have been labeled
misinformation and it just seems like
this is a conversation that's a lot
bigger than tate i agree it affects you
know you it affects me it affects anyone
with a microphone so i really invite
people out there i don't care if you
like or dislike what andrew tate is
saying if you don't want to be next on
the shopping block because somebody
decides that your opinion isn't good or
isn't in line with the group think
that's being you know
labeled as right
in this moment then you should oppose
these bans if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]